Most marketing plans will start with
a lot of what we learned in lesson one,
like who's your audience?
Who are the personas, or
what segments are you going to focus on?
You'll consider your competitive
analysis and your value proposition.
So now we've identified
our marketing goals,
we can focus on creating
our distribution plan.
The distribution plan
will focus on how and
where we're going to reach
our potential customers.
Now of course, we're not trying to
make a full marketing plan that
the chief marketing officer at
a Fortune 500 company might make.
But we try to focus on the most
effective parts of the plan, that
will help you figure out your action
plan to take your product to market.
But first, we need to do some research.
There are a few tools and
different options we'll go over to
help you conduct market research.
The goal is to look for insights that'll
allow us to select some starting points,
not to come up with
a super elaborate plan.
Remember marketing is all about making
a hypothesis, testing the market, and
then adjusting.
Be sure to write down your
hypothesis and results, so
you that you learn what worked and
what didn't work.
Now we're going to go ahead and
use Ebarknet as our research example
when we talk about different tools.
I encourage you to follow
along with your own app, or
feel free to follow along with
Ebarknet if you don't have one yet.